é melhor pagar iptu ipva visto ou parcelado
acompanhe o vídeo até o fim e eu te explico tudo
bora lá
está próximo o momento de pagar
o imposto sobre propriedade de veículos automotores
o ipva e o imposto predial e territorial urbano iptu
e tem um planejamento financeiro para esse momento
é muito importante
cada estado oferece condições diferentes
mas normalmente
pagar à vista é melhor por conseguir maior desconto
mas é preciso avaliar sua condição financeira
para escolher a melhor forma de pagamento
se sua condição financeira está mais apertada
o parcelamento é uma opção natural
parcele de maneira a não pressionar demais
o seu orçamento mensal
evite ao máximo recorrer a empréstimos
limites de cheque especial
ou outros tipos de crédito
com juros que possam gerar uma mola de neve
com base nos últimos anos
os descontos para quem pagar à vista
varia entre 3% de desconto do ipva e de 4% do iptu
existem casos
inclusive de estados que oferecem até 10% de abatimento
se você tiver uma reserva financeira não duvide
preferi fazer o pagamento à vista com desconto
gostou das dicas
pois dê uma olhada na nossa playlist
até o próximo vídeo tchau tchau